بعد اطلاق قوات الاحتلال قنابل الالغاز
تجاه
المستشفى اذا اصابات في صفوف المرضى في
هذا المستشفى ربما حول هذا الموضوع انضم
الينا ايضا من جنين محمود السعدي مدير
مركز الاسعاف والطوارئ بالهلال الاحمر
الفلسطيني في محافظه جنين اهلا بك معنا
ربما تعليق وتعقيب على ما جاء في هذا
العاجل
ما يقارب حوالي ساعتين وقوات الاحتلال ما
زالتتاح المخيم
والمنطقه الغربيه من مدينه جنين والمخيم
المتاخر للمدينه اليات عسكريه كبيره
همم تم ابلاغنا من قبل الصليب الاحمر في
عدم الدخول للمخيم الا بوجود تنسيق لنقل
واخلاق الاصابات والجرحى من داخل المخيم
تمكن نحن من نقل اصابه وهناك ااه الجنون
حديثه تبدا من اجل الاخلاق عدد الاصابات
قبل قليل قبل الحديث معك
وردنا كمان اتصالات اا تم دخول سيارات
الاسعاف والسماح لها قبل قليل في اخلاء
بعض المصابين من همم داخل المخيم لا هناك
همم عمليه صعوبه تمام نتلقاها من عمليه
الدخول المخيم بسبب وجود عوائق للاليات
العسكريه المتواجده على مداخل المخيم طيب
بما يخص الاصابات المسجله حتى اللحظه كيف
يمكن ان تصفهالا
المعظم الاصابات
في طريق
الاهالي وبعض تم نقلها من قبل طواقم
الاسعاف هناك همم حديث عن الشهداء الا
لانه همم بعض وكالات الانباء تناقلت هناك
ثلاثه شهداء هناك شهيدين لا نعرف تحديدا
همم دقه المعلومات لان هناك الاجتياح ما
زال متواصل ومستمر على على المخيم وانا
اتحدث معك هناك هناك اصوات لاطلاق النار
ما زالت همم تصدر من داخل مخيم جميل همم
كانت على جهزيه عاليه من اجل همم
جباره من اجل الوصول ونقل الاصابات داخل
المخيم لان هناك همم عمليه الدخول كانت
هناك محفوفه في عدد كبير من المخاطر نقل
الاصابات واخلاقها من داخل المخيم لان
عمليه التنسيق تحتاج الى وقت حوالي ربع
ساعه من اجل السماح السيارات بالدخول
للمخيم واخلاق المصابين وهذه ال ال 15
دقيقه تحول دون تقديم الخدمه اللازمه
للمصابين اللي هم بحاجه لكل دقيقه من اجل
اخلائهم
وتلقي العلاج الطبي لهم طيب هذا الصعوبه
في الدخول بسبب ربما منع ايضا قوه
الاحتلال دخول طواقم الاسعاف الى جنين الى
مخيم جنين تحديدا ما هي الصعوبات التي
يمكن ان تواجهها
الصعوبات هناك المناطق اشتباكات هناك اليه
عسكريه هناك يوجد قناصه همم مركزين على
بعض البنايات همم
تحول دون عمليه التقدم وهناك فواتير
بالاليات عسكريه متواجده هي التي تمنعنا
من الوصول الى المخيم حاليا
تنسيقات حديثه تجرى من اجل السماح طواقنا
في الدخول هو قبل قليل هناك سمح لسيارات
الاسعاف في الدخول من اجل همم اخلاء بعض
المصابين من داخل المخيم
بهذا شكرا لكم
طوارئ بالهلال الاحمر الفلسطيني